the washington post is an
extraordinarily biased source it has
been extraordinarily by a source
for many many years but i have to say
this may be the worst major media
correction i have ever seen in my life
it's pretty astonishing so you will
recall that way back
in december the washington post reported
a call
the call was supposed to be between
president trump
and a georgia investigator okay and that
georgia investigator
he apparently told according to the
washington post that this georgia
investigator would be quote
a national hero if they found the fraud
he apparently encouraged this georgia
investigator to quote unquote find the
fraud and said they would be a national
hero
if they did so okay now
now it turns out that those quotes were
entirely fabricated like top to bottom
made up according to the washington post
correction quote
two months after publication of this
story the georgia secretary of state
released an audio recording of president
donald trump's december phone call with
the state's top elections investigator
the recording revealed that the post
misquoted trump's comments on the call
based on information provided by a
source so in other words they talked to
a single source
who was supposedly privileged to the
phone call that person made up quotes
the washington post
simply quoted that source without any
sort of actual sourcing
and then when the phone call broke as in
like a couple of months after the story
when it broke in february march then it
turned out none of this was on the phone
call and the washington post
had to retract basically the center of
the story
now this is a separate phone call from
the one that happened that we all heard
the audio of president trump and brad
raffensberger the georgia secretary of
state
at the time i said it was easy to
mischaracterize that conversation as
trump
telling raffensberger that he needed to
find votes somewhere that were
fraudulent it was the opposite
right what he was saying in that phone
call was he believed i think baselessly
that there were a bunch of
votes in georgia that were improper and
that raffensburger was ignoring that
evidence and he was encouraging to go
find the evidence that trump thought
existed
but you could read it the other way but
something that certainly never happened
that we know at this point is that trump
never said that you would be a
quote-unquote national hero
if you find the fraud and didn't tell
the investigator to find the fraud or
say
that she would be a quote national hero
if she did so instead trump urged the
investigator to scrutinize ballots in
fulton county georgia asserting she
would find dishonesty there he also told
her she had the most important job
in the country right now the headline
and text of the post report have now
been corrected to remove quotes
misattributed to trump the newspaper
says
i mean you know dangerous that is
seriously like as a matter of journalism
you know how crazy it is that you had
quotes in a headline
that were attributed to the president of
the united states based on a single
unnamed source
and it turns out that it was just a lie
it was just made up the correction comes
days after the wall street journal
obtained
audio of the december call between trump
and the investigator trump told francis
watson the chief investigator of the
georgia secretary of state's office
quote when the right answer comes out
you'll be praised watson reportedly
responded i can assure you that our team
and the georgia bureau of investigation
we are only interested in the truth and
finding information based on the facts
the original post report according to
the hill shook the political world just
days after the january 5th runoff
elections in georgia
a contest both republican senators lost
giving democrats the majority
in the upper chamber the original post
report was covered widely by many media
outlets including the hill which has
also updated its report
on the trump call hey now here is the
thing that's amazing
you will you'll remember that there were
other outlets that then
confirmed the posts reporting so what
happened is the post reported stuff that
wasn't true
and then it turns out that they had to
walk that back but at the time
after the post reported that trump had
said find the fraud you'll be a national
hero if you do so
at the time there were other outlets
that confirmed the reporting
and that led people who watch the media
to say okay well if you have a bunch of
outlets that are now confirming the same
story well now
you can pretty much guarantee that the
story is true except what if that's not
true
what if the way that the media now do
business when there is a republican
president
is they find a anonymous source that
anonymous source then tells their story
to the washington post
and then that same exact anonymous
source goes over to cbs news
and says that exact same untrue story
and then cbs news says based on our
source we can also confirm that we have
heard that the story is true
so basically you now have a single
source who is dictating news to a wide
variety of mainstream
media outlets and because these
mainstream media outlets are granting
these people the privilege of speaking
on background meaning anonymously this
means there is no way to confirm
whether you have more than one source
confirming the story is true right
normally
when you have the washington post make a
report and then the new york times
confirms that report
the assumption is that there is one
source for the new york times and one
source for the washington post
and so multiple sources have now doubled
right double sourcing is the way that
journalism is supposed to work you're
supposed to have two sources who
corroborate or report not just one
okay but the way that the media now work
is one anonymous source goes to the
washington post and says something
that's untrue
that same person because they've now
been quoted anonymously in the
washington post
the same person now goes to the new york
times tells the exact same story
and the new york times says we can
confirm the washington post reporting
but can you because apparently you're
now like how many stories have been
laundered
into multiple outlets by one person
i'm sure this has happened multiple
times this happened one time it happened
many times
according to the daily wire real clear
investigation senior writer mark
hemingway says this kind of mistake is
beyond serious there's zero
accountability
in major corporate media yet they
continually insist they're the ones
holding the line on the truth
and always remember what should scare
you about the media is what doesn't get
exposed note the headline on the
post-follow-up story it's sort of
maliciously anodyne
recording reviews reveals details of
trump call to georgia's chief elections
investigator
it's not trump's remarks grossly
misrepresented across media because
would credulously fall for political ops
mary katherine hamm of cnn she says that
somebody should lose their job
she said so they made up quotes wasn't
the actual f the header for the story
could be a little clearer like our bad
we made fake news that led the national
news for weeks and this audio proves it
for those in my timeline asking if it
really matters because trump is bad
anyway
yes it really matters quotes being
correct matters a lot
don't you see that's the issue if a
reporter is so dead sure that quote
trump bad anyway he's less inclined to
question
or vet his own stories and don't give me
the corrections are an example of the
system working stuff
sometimes they are here they're coming
in three months later when they are
outed by a recording and the correction
and new story are designed to downplay
as much as possible
not blair as loudly as the original
again it's a pretty amazing thing so
they directly
misattributed quotes they didn't
paraphrase right they put it in
quotation marks they said trump said x
trump never said x they did it based on
anonymous sourcing and then
they laundered that into multiple media
outlets and this was
by the way this was quoted in the
impeachment papers for trump the second
time around
that report was quoted in the
impeachment papers and it was charge 10
in the impeachment papers okay that's
pretty unbelievable so they laundered
a false piece of news into an
impeachment and then they wonder why we
don't trust them then they wonder why
the credibility of the media is on edge
it also demonstrates full scale that the
fact-checking media are just garbage
it shows that the fact-checking media
are willing to cover for pretty much
anything so long as it comes from one of
their buddies because the way that this
works
is that if you are a member of the
establishment approved media you can say
anything
and your fact-checking buddies will
cover up for you but if you're a member
of the non-establishment media
then they will come after you with a
pickaxe for saying something that is
true but they disagree with
it really is an impressive show here the
fact again
that the washington post blew this story
so badly
and the fact that the entire media are
now rushing to the defense of the
washington post
should tell you something it should tell
you something
so it's it is pretty amazing again the
original washington post story
did break i believe on january january
6th
is when it originally broke or i'm sorry
the the the original news was was broken
before january 6th
and january 5th was before the georgia
runoff i believe so may have had an
impact on an incredibly tight georgia
runoff election
that's not exactly a shocker glenn
kessler the washington post fact-checker
he said the washington post reporting on
trump's call to the georgia secretary of
state
undisputed as the audio tape was
obtained from the start was the article
cited in the impeachment article trump
naturally pretends otherwise
but that's not actually true actually
they they reveal
they actually refer to i believe both
stories
so impressive showing by the meat but
this is what our media are now
cnn spends all day just covering fox
news
that's all the media do the media cover
people in conservative news
and they report false stories and they
launder the false stories through
multiple media outlets and then
they give themselves nice fact checks
very very convenient stuff
for our mainstream media who are doing
an excellent job journalism
because this is what they do and again
the false news always rockets around
earth faster than the real news
you wonder why president trump had a lot
of ground to cover
he had such fertile ground when he would
talk about fake news the answer is
because we in the conservative community
have known for decades that the media do
this kind of crap
okay this goes well back before bernard
goldberg put out the book bias in the
early 2000s
i remember my parents cancelling their
subscriptions to los angeles times in
the mid 90s
over the los angeles times running a
picture of a of a
supposedly palestinian man supposedly
being beaten by an israeli soldier on
their front page
the caption was false it turned out that
it was a man attempting to escape
palestinian rock throwers and an israeli
soldier shouting at the people trying to
throw rocks at the guy
the fake news has been a thing for quite
a while and all the mistakes are in one
direction
when is the last time they made a
mistake in the direction of
conservatives
can you name one i mean literally one
can you name
a mistake that has been made in the
direction of republicans the answer of
course
is no and these kind of stories happen
regularly
people lose their jobs over this kind of
stuff and we've talked on this program
in the past several weeks
about the about the media simply taking
comments by particular people and then
deliberately misinterpreting them to get
them fired there's an entire washington
post story
that came on the heels of a georgetown
professor being fired for saying
something not racist and the entire
angle of the story is that it was racist
there are a couple of types of bias that
the media can go through one is
selection bias what they cover and what
they don't
they won't cover andrew cuomo being a
corrupt tool bag until a couple of
months after the election then they'll
start covering it so selection bias is
one thing
and then there is the way they cover
stories right the angle of the story
that is another area of bias
and then the third is the worst kind of
bias and that is where they will just
believe whatever confirms their priors
and then they will just report that
credits credulously out and then later
if they get it wrong they'll walk it
back let's not pretend that these folks
have any stake in the in the objective
truth when i say these folks don't mean
everybody in the media but there are
enough of them
that it is indicative of a broader
problem in the media they refuse to
face up to facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content